[Music]
brennan joins us up next in virginia
brennan welcome to the show
hey guys thanks for having me absolutely
how can we help
yeah i just wanted to touch base with
you guys and
you know i'm 27 um i have a home
um i still have college debt i have um a
car loan
and i have investments in crypto um
and really just want to navigate i have
forty thousand dollars saved um in my
in my savings
and i just wanna talk to you guys and
see what is the next
you know best path forward
um you know for financial freedom yeah
it's a great question how much uh
student loan debt do you have left
i only have thirty four thousand thirty
four and how much is the car
payment
sorry the car loan
sixteen thousand fifteen okay and you
said you have a home you have a mortgage
yes sir okay
but i got a sweet deal on that so the
home is valued at four hundred and
twenty thousand i only owe two hundred
thousand
okay and how much do you have in crypto
14 000. okay
well you did great saving up i mean
you have a you have a great savings
account starting out um
so overall here here's the way we
we kind of take our stands brandon so
we want you to be on the path of the
fastest possible way to
have financial peace and to build wealth
and so what we have found over decades
is that fastest path is being completely
debt free because your largest wealth
building tool is your income and when
your income comes in and it's not going
back out to student loans and a car
payment you have more money to go and
invest in things that have long track
records
and so getting to that point is really
where where we would suggest you go so
what does that mean that means if i'm in
your if i woke up in your shoes
um and george you can answer this
question if anything's different but for
me if i woke up in rachel's heels
what would you do
i
i would get out of the crypto i'd i'd
sell it cash it out
get your 14 000 because then you're
gonna have fifty four thousand dollars
uh in savings and you're gonna be able
to
knock out all your debt right there and
so being able to pay off the car i'd pay
that off tomorrow
um go ahead and pay off the student
loans and then build up a three to six
month worth of expenses
um emergency fund the fully funded
emergency fund
you can put that in a money market
account a savings account but just
having that buffer of cash
that if or when something happens just
in case it's there
and then i would start investing 15 of
your income into retirement and
when we talk about investing it really
is the things that have proven track
records and so we love mutual funds if
you have
a job that offers a 401k and a match
doing that taking you know getting into
a roth ira
um having these elements that
involve compound interest and again
being in the market some and right now
it's on sale because it's down uh but
really seeing okay what are the things
that have long track records and then at
that point if you want to get back into
crypto a little bit i think that's
totally fine if it's a small percentage
of your world i just wouldn't have a ton
of money in something that does not have
a long track record and crypto could get
there um but as of right now i would put
myself in a position where i'm debt-free
and have cash in the bank
how does that hit you brendan
yeah
that i kind of knew what you guys were
going to say i just wanted to hear it
from you know from the horse's mouth so
to speak um he called you a horse ranger
[Music]
i don't take offense
yeah okay um i meant like the pros um
but
so
i've been talking to my father about it
as well and he you know he said
something along the lines of doubling up
my payments that way
oh
just so you guys know i also so
um i make about 75 000 a year
and um
and um
so but i also rent out two of my rooms
so 75 percent of my mortgage is paid for
oh awesome so
yeah and luckily you know i have good
roommates
um
and i'm not in a committed relationship
thank god um so
what the next part is is do i
what i was really thinking of do i pay
off the car
and
make double payments on the student
loans and then invest into a roth ira
what i what my car payment was well i
think you're going to be able to be if
i'm real you can go and just pay
everything off and then and then you're
going to be investing really soon and
the the time frame between now
and when you after you have your fully
funded emergency fund it's not going to
be that long maybe a couple of months
for you because you're already ahead
five grand in what you have right now
and you don't have a ton of expenses um
as a single guy so i i think you'll be
investing really really soon anyways if
i if this was going to take you five
years until you start investing then i
would still have the same answer but i
would also be like oh i know that
doesn't feel great but i think you're
gonna be able to start inve you're gonna
be able to invest here in the next like
five months i think you could open
something up and that in that time
period is not gonna make or break you i
would rather you
be completely debt-free have no payments
have some cash in the bank and then you
can really start investing at that point
brandon what got you here isn't going to
get you there what i'm seeing is you're
doing a lot of things right now all at
once and it's not getting you to where
you want to go and so when i started
this plan back in 2013 i had about this
similar debt you had i had forty
thousand dollars in debt student loans
credit cards and i followed the baby
steps i put a thousand dollars aside the
rest went towards that i had to cash out
some uh stocks i had from apple when i
worked there as part of their employee
stock purchase program i cash that it
hurt to cash that out but man seeing
that debt go away and seeing those
payments go away and have that income
back in my life and then i went oh i
have so much more money to invest now
when i don't have any payments and so
the good news is on paper you could be
close to debt free today
if you cashed out the crypto and used
all the savings except for a thousand
dollars that would get you almost to
debt freedom and then you save up that
three to six months which with your
income and you renting out those rooms
you're going to be able to do in a few
months and then you're going to be able
to invest 15
and then you can start betting on crypto
again
so this is not a five-year plan we're
talking
within the next six seven months you're
in a very different place financially
i can tell you're not you're not wanting
to do this
well the the the trade-off is is that
you know i know that crypto's very
speculative market and that and that
honestly is an indication of the price
fluctuation and i think we all know that
especially people that understand the
financial world it's all right now based
on speculation but
there are going to be winners and losers
in the space
and if you do your due diligence and you
find out
what those true winners are that bring
real world utility
it's almost
it's almost you should bet on that
because the the
upside to that it's almost like well why
not put 14 000 that you can afford to
lose you can't afford it and you're
broke dude
okay i don't know what to tell you i
mean on paper
i know you're you're here's 40 000 in
the savings and you have
what is it 49 000 in in debt
no that's not right right
here's the thing i'm hearing language
like this you said multiple times well i
only have 34 000 student loans well i
only have 15 000 on my car
well i only owe 200 000 on my house as
long as you see debt in that way
you can't build wealth
because you see debt as a tool to be
leveraged
and clearly it's not working you're
doing too many things at once and i want
you to win man i'm really rooting for
you and i'm not mad at crypto this is
not a thing i'm not bashing crypto i
don't care what if it was single stocks
i'd tell you to cash it out right now
what you need to do is clean up this
mess so you can have your greatest
wealth building tool back in your life
your income
that's what we're here to do we're not
here to tell you you're doing things
wrong i think it's awesome that you're
27 and you own a house and you clearly
know a thing or two and you're smart i
mean you're you have roommates they're
helping pay them more i mean yeah you're
do you're doing it right but the problem
too is is over time when you just keep
sitting in this
you're it's going to take you longer to
build wealth and again our plan is to
get to the fastest point from point a to
point b how do you do that and we found
time and time again not just in a math
sense too but also there's an emotional
spiritual sense too that when you do not
owe anyone anything
you have options and investing in things
that have long track records that have
been proven over time is the wisest way
to get from point a to point b preach
rachel preach